welcome to this video of a sautee whole
us at you I don't know okay this is Owen
I'm going to play more Sicilian now
let's see i get the Kalashnikov in an
opening then i have want to learn I not
have yet mastered it i cannot i have a
hard time to remember remember the lines
and what was this be five or not or not
I don't know hmm not really sure if you
go be five here or not now it isn't it
isn't so bad in any case okay so what do
we have here wants to go to be six maybe
ok I can I can play that move it's not a
not a problem so before check then
Bishop g5 yep this looks like normal
sheshna cough Kalashnikov type of play
yeah I'm not a huge fan of my my queen
side pawns having moved so often but
well it happened it happened to that way
okay night dear phone and then we should
be sick sob should be six immediately
I'm not sure about that i know i can
actually no i managed to give him a pawn
here i think with nida form now with the
night on the white doesn't have many
squares once I'm I don't know
yeah okay let's put it on the floor
first and then think about the details
we should be three was the move all that
one oh I didn't think about that one at
all and possibly not so bad but it
didn't really didn't really think about
it okay um tix here no Bishop d5 CD
astound downright stupid so let's take
he has to take with the pawn and what
now yeah 55 cakes yeah I will ever get
the a porn at the end Bishop t5i ticket
I can take with the pawn the night f5
that that should be ok push up to five
CD Pont XD form it's got Queen III it's
not really needing too much ok ok I
spent far too much time for this pretty
a pretty unspectacular position I could
have played that much much quicker
yeah it's very symmetrical that he's got
just rock d 2 of course not quite sure
what is what he is thinking about oh
he's giving up the airport for rock da
door no I don't know bit of a stranger
IDM
look at the end and don't I don't get it
really it can also go look ab1 now what
is he doing then Queen d700 I don't know
ok I want that phone
taking a photo and preparing to march
the apron
I definitely need to play move like that
at one point then don't want to want to
run into into possible checkmates all
the time Queen f2 is going to go here
okay they have to speed up a little bit
now that wasn't so great really wasn't
so great queena forza just a little
trick okay this is an eye blink is
unprotected check I'm so maybe I don't
just stepping up can you believe that
it's probably even good right that's
even okay don't have anything great iam
check check check check
check
check check yeah okay this guy he wants
to win on time hey snow no other way to
put it basically killing his own
position but trying to trying to win on
time there may be managers so it's
tricky I don't have much time left look
at you two
g6 is also a good enjoy taking taking
away some crucial squares
you
yeah unless he at xf7 I'll play G 642
made next rook G tomatoes that is the
move I don't see a made yet after F for
which is probably just me being blind
look at sheet white resign it is I don't
see the made yet it's just probably my
my problem yeah I don't see it chasis is
this a mate I don't see a maid rookie to
isn't made Chad probably would have
would have gone with her with a bunch of
checks here hoping hoping to catch him I
hope this is winning as well check would
be kind of okay well this is this is
trading that's not a good idea yeah this
it is a win certainly yeah I don't know
he simply should have should have
repeated I guess or I don't know here
Queen c3 was winning okay I of course I
cannot go to a five that then this was a
strong move rook and queen a five yeah
the computer is just completely fact
check it doesn't really matter for him
he sees that the apron is going to
promote and I'm running running away
with the king okay yeah i was i was
satisfied I mean satisfied him I I was
pretty much giving up her yeah in terms
of a draw is ok with 30 seconds but he
just he wanted to check he rather wanted
to kill himself and try to win on time
yeah it is far too risky really here h5
was already made in a couple
check check check yeah that's it check
makes sure that everything is happening
let's check him it's quite quite nice
yeah I want to check 11 situation
briefly here yeah this is this I did not
expected this move and he I wasn't sure
I wanted to take maybe I can go to be
five I was thinking this but I wasn't
sure about this is remove ah that's a
very neat tactic I didn't see that one I
was thinking I cannot take because of
this but suppose check there's a fork I
didn't see that one okay that's nice
okay interesting game and thanks for
watching